well an arrest has been made in
connection to a deadly crash where two
people lost their lives that crash
happened may 24th on jones near flamingo
someone driving a corvette traveling
north on jones at a high rate of speed
high rate of speed that is hit a median
police say and ended up in a parking lot
victoria saha joins us from that site
where police have charged another driver
victoria
two lives were lost in a crash right by
this church here near flamingo and jones
back in late may police say it was a
result of two cars racing and today
family of one of the victims say they
can finally start to heal as an arrest
was made for one of the drivers involved
this is the aftermath of the crash that
killed 34 old priscilla velasquez and
her boyfriend 34 year-old jason kuhar
according to a police report obtained by
8 news nile velazquez was the registered
owner of the corvette kuhar was driving
it when he lost control causing it to
crash and overturn the report also says
the corvette was going nearly 140 miles
per hour the investigation revealed the
corvette was racing against a dodge
challenger metro's fatal detectives
located the driver of that car giovanni
monaris tavezon he was arrested by
police on wednesday arrest reports show
manaris tavezon drove away after he
witnessed the crash claire velasquez is
a sister-in-law of priscilla velasquez
they were waiting for those involved to
be held accountable priscilla wouldn't
have been okay with it
like i feel like she would have been
scared it was so unnecessary and there's
all these people that are affected
because of
mistakes
and and we're all sitting here kind of
dealing with it and
it's just the sad reality of it all the
velasquez family was not able to discuss
the crash in detail or the arrest but
say their main focus right now is to
take care of the two teens velasquez
left behind manaris tavazon is facing
felony charges of reckless driving
resulting in substantial bodily harm or
death he faced a judge yesterday and has
since posted bail he will be back in
court again in july
reporting near flamingo and jones
victoria saha live local now